[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Anu Srivastava,
and I'm going
to show you how you can use
Vertex AI to train and serve
a TensorFlow model using
code in a custom container.
We'll be using a data set of
technical specs of automobiles
to build a model
that can predict
the fuel efficiency of late
1970s and early 1980s cars.
You can find this
data set on Kaggle.
We must provide the
model with description
of several automobiles
from that time period.
The description
includes attributes
like cylinders, displacement,
horsepower, and weight.
We're working mainly
in a notebook,
so think of this as an
interactive web tool
where you can combine code,
computational output, text,
and multimedia resources
in a single home.
So we've set up a container in
here, a portable environment
for working with our model.
Don't worry.
We have all the source
code and instructions
for you in a Codelab to
try this out at home.
So now that everything's set
up in here, let's train the job
on the platform.
I can go here to
the Trainings tab.
Create a new job.
I'll name my demo, add
a few other settings,
like our container
URL and compute specs,
and now it's off to the races.
This one actually takes
10 to 15 minutes to train,
so I ran a job ahead of time
so we can test it out together.
So now that it's trained,
we deploy an endpoint.
And we can now use this
back in our notebook.
So now for the moment of truth.
Let's predict a sample.
I've added a cell down
here with a sample case.
So this is a set of attributes
that we described earlier,
but they've been
normalized, which
is why they don't look
exactly like, say, a year
or the weight of a car.
I hit Run, and we can see that
an automobile with these values
would give us approximately
16 miles per gallon.
So to make this
visual, I can use
a lot of ready-to-go
functionality
to visualize my data down here.
Use graphs and charts
to share your findings
with your friends.
We hope we've inspired you to
try working with your own data.
Or to recreate this demo,
check out the links provided.
[MUSIC PLAYING]